Now we are at the end of this lesson, and I
just want to wrap it up by summarizing what we've seen. We talked
about black-box testing, the testing of
software based on a functional specification,
a description of the software rather than its code. We saw a
systematic way of doing that, that allows for breaking down the problem
of testing software, so the problem of going from this functional specification
to a set of test cases into smaller steps, more manageable steps.
And we saw two main ways of doing this. One by identifying
relevant inputs for the main features in the system
and then deriving test case specifications and test cases from
this set of inputs. And the second way by
building a model for the main features of the system
and then using this model to decide how to
test the system. In the next lesson, we are going
to discuss, how to do testing by looking inside the
box? So, how to do testing in a white-box fashion.